[Musique]
ces jeunes élèves qui posent pour la
photo souvenir sont les futurs
agriculteurs ou intervenant dans le
monde agricole de demain à la réunion le
temps d'une demi journée ils ont été
sensibilisés à la place de l'europe dans
le monde agricole et au sein du
développement rural binche et là pour
comprendre comment fonctionne le
territoire surtout comprendre un peu
mieux le système agricole de la réunion
les aides du comment fonctionnent les
agriculteurs comment ils peuvent obtenir
les ressources pour pouvoir continuer
leur métier
quatre ateliers en pédagogie active sont
ainsi proposés et ce sont les animateurs
du centre régional information jeunesse
réunion qui présente les dispositifs
européens
mes collègues formateur qui vont donc
présenter ses différentes aides
proposées par l'europe ainsi que les
différentes formations post-bac
existantes à la réunion les métiers
possibles en termes de débouchés et
aussi différents ateliers des changes et
de débats autour des enjeux liés au
monde agricole
une action de sensibilisation porté par
le département de la réunion qui est
autorité de gestion du feader les fonds
européen agricole pour le développement
rural à la réunion une journée animée en
partenariat avec la daf et le crij
réunion et il s'agissait du coup bas
d'en faire découvrir l'europe savoir ce
que c'est qu'est ce que ça représente
les aides qui sont associés la place des
aides européennes dans le
une école rurale qu'il est qu'ils aient
connaissance de ces aides et notamment
des fonds feader pour pour demain
pouvoir être aidées dans la culture
métisse au total cinq opérations de
sensibilisation comme celles ci ont été
menées auprès de jeunes en formation
agricole de jeunes acteurs qui
participeront au développement de
l'agriculture et du monde rural à la
réunion soutenue par les fonds européens
[Musique]